talk hello okay we're good
i think we are all right until
the notification goes out
okay
yo blacksmith's forge what up lord vader
you were very close to being first there
we go got it
what is up everybody lots of stuff to
talk about today
it's kind of crazy oh all
everything that's going on right now is
just pretty much kind of crazy
oh yeah it's all starting to mix up into
itself as well it's crazy crazy crazy
look let me hear uh if we get chris here
yeah
we got chris i hear him hey that's me
okay just want to make sure you weren't
like insanely loud some people were
saying last time what's up everyone
all right me and chris here
chris is uh my roommate my editor my
friend uh
and he is uh one of the hosts of cosmic
culture the main host i'm on there
just a little bit every now and then
every now and then i pop on but it is
our joint channel but he uh he runs it
and everything
so if you haven't subscribed to chris at
cosmic culture we are giving away shield
right here it's behind warren right now
it's right there we're giving away
shield in
what six days yeah end of the month
we'll be announcing it
six days yeah uh we'll be giving away a
shield in six days if you guys just uh
sub to cosmic culture our channel
that we talk about things together and
just kind of nerd out
but hey they announced uh
we got an announcement that captain
america
chris evans is captain america could be
making a return
and this was actually reported back in
january i think it was deadline or
variety i have them all pulled up on my
other screen here let me check it out
deadline or variety uh reported it let's
show it right here see right here
captain america four captain america
four
chris evans returning to marvel
cinematic universe can you guys see that
you guys can't see it
chris evans returning to marvel
cinematic universe
in some vague way and this was you can
see right here january 14th
right here january 14th of this year and
then after that
yesterday we got all these captain
america
four in development with falcon
and the winter soldier ep executive
producer
malcolm smelman writing so a new captain
america movie coming out
um that's exciting so
what's actually very interesting is
these are
two different projects these are two new
different captain america projects
um those stated by variety that there is
the captain america 4 coming
with the head writer malcolm spellman
that's probably going to
going to be like sam wilson's captain
america
and then we have another project that
apparently is about chris evans
returning and
that's pretty huge i didn't think we
were going to get chris evans back in
the mcu
what do you think chris well you know it
brings up a ton of questions and for me
it really can only go two directions
because there's no way they're going to
have chris evans come back and
overshadow
the new captain america right they're
not they're not going to want him to
overshadow sam so
the options are that's going to be the
story of when he went back in time you
know they asked oh
what happened he was like i'd rather not
say we're going to get that story that'd
be cool
or they're setting up secret wars and
this is gonna be a different universe
and we might even see sam versus chris
evans you know and
and that might be a fight we see in
secret wars somehow that'd be really
cool too
yeah but i don't see them trying to
overshadow sam
yeah that's a good point and i think
that is actually why they're making two
different captain america movies
because if they just did a captain
america movie with chris evans coming
back
that wouldn't be good for for sam's
captain america
right now i i don't
i don't know if they're too much
concerned about that i
i don't know if they're s i know they're
setting up secret wars let's just make
that like clear right now
i know they're setting up secret wars
but this is like that's like the next
in game right that's the next end game
yeah like
10 years from now unfortunately right so
they have to build that back up again
so that that's that's when i want to see
like robert downey jr come back again
that's when i want to see
you know chris evans mark ruffalo i want
to see all the originals come back yo
adam what's up my dude
thank you for that super chat always
coming in clutch on twitch he would come
and clutch and
donate and donate subs and stuff so
thanks my man
um yeah but i want to see all of them
come back for secret wars but i think
that's like way down the line but chris
evans returning as captain america
i think what you said as far as the
storyline is concerned i'd
really really like to see what happened
when he went back in time
and i think there's so much story there
because you know he went way back you
know he didn't go back like
when he's old right um he went
back i mean i don't know how old
peggy carter was at the time hold he was
kind let's say they're like 35 right
so there's so much happening there
there's so much story that could be told
there
you know with all the knowledge that he
had and granted the timeline might have
screwed things up like when he went back
he might have screwed things up
with the timeline but like with all the
knowledge that he had
did he invest in apple did he invest in
google
right he's a super soldier did he play
football like
what did he there's so much story that
could happen there and there could be
like the conflict of
no i'm not going to interfere because i
know everything because
that's not fair you know what i mean or
maybe
maybe i maybe i'm a little bit more
relaxed now like i was an avengers in
game and everything
let's go get that son of a bee and like
hey maybe i'm gonna throw some money at
apple here maybe i'll throw some money
in some
tesla and other investments you know but
there's a lot dark industries
right stark industries you know there's
a lot of story to be told there
that's the other the other question is
um
when he goes back you know he returns
all the stuff he doesn't return but does
he continue being captain america
right i don't think it does does he go
behind the scenes and become like
captain america of the shadows and he's
out saving puppy for trees and nobody
knows what he's doing it is
that's a whole other storyline too there
possibly well then you also have to
consider
is is the other captain is there two
captain america's on that timeline now
are there two yeah he has to kind of see
he says he knows he'll mess everything
up well not only that but like
the other like the the current what we
would call it
or the main captain america of that
timeline would be in the ice
adam thank you like my adidas jacket i
love it
thanks for that super chat um but
there's so much story for them
to do with chris evans returning and i
don't i don't think it's going to be a
part
of this captain america 4 that we're
going to get with malcolm spellman
writing it i think it's going to be
completely separate gonna take place in
mcu but probably
like the best way to do it would be put
it in that other timeline
because it doesn't really affect the
continuity that much like oh yeah the
other timeline's being affected who
really cares right
and if they do that that's the big
question are they leading to connect it
sometime or do they want to just give us
another captain america movie because
they know everybody wants to see steve
rogers again
right well also with loki and the tva
maybe they can tie it in that way
because maybe and it could only just be
like
you see loki you did this this and this
it's a problem
see steve rogers went back in time and
it was fine because he's a good guy
but you're doing this this loki you're
screwing everything up
if anybody's investing in apple and
bitcoin is logan right right
hold on real fast alexander bench i hope
i pronounced that right but thank you so
much for that that's super chat i really
appreciate it
um so yeah so new captain america movie
um or two new captain america movies one
with presumably
sam wilson um and the other with chris
evans captain america let's go ahead and
read uh
let's go ahead and read some of the
articles here that i have right here
um so captain america for in development
let me move my let me move me a little
bit here
so everybody can see
so all right cool captain america four
in development with falcon and the
winter soldier
uh executive producer malcolm spellman
ryan this is what it says
this is from deadline who is pretty
legitimate like
everything that comes from deadline is
usually pretty legit
um in the wake of falcon in the winter
soldiers season finale last night at
disney plus
the show runner malcolm spellman is
already busy with dallin
musson on a fourth captain america
deadline can report so
it says while not confirmed sources say
the project spelman is writing could be
one focused on anthony mackie sam wilson
character
while the possible chris evans captain
america project would be
separate and that's what it says right
here uh chris evans captain america
project
would be separate so the one that they
have planned that was reported
uh by variety i have that in another tab
right here
this one right here this one was january
14th
so this one that's being reported by
variety this project is different
than the one that apparently malcolm
spellman who was the writer for the
falcon in the winter soldier
was writing um and when he when they say
while it's not confirmed that means
marvel
they reached out to marvel and they
didn't say anything which
they don't ever say anything because
that's that would be confirming
you know a movie you know this would be
uh phase five for sure or but beyond i
shouldn't say would
only be phase five it's definitely gonna
be after phase four is what i should say
so phase five faith six
um since variety reported this here in
january
i'm gonna say that that something is in
the works um
has been in the works and and just it
says right here
right so just two years after retiring
as the avengers leader evans is eyeing a
return to the marvel
cinematic universe in some nebulous
capacity
um yeah and this one
pretty much goes on to just talk about
the falcon of the winter soldier about
the finale which we won't talk about
we're not here to ruin the finale for
anybody
um no directors we're casting an
attachment as of yet marvel wasn't
available for
comment um so we're getting two new
captain america movies
two new i do have one more thought hit
me with that one
of what chris evans movie could be about
so they make this joke in the first
episode of falcon in the winter soldier
about oh cap's on the moon right
right they've they've they've played but
they kind of leaned into that a few
times probably four or five times that
was mentioned throughout the series
yeah so what if somehow captain america
ends up going up with
nick fury to the peak the sword base
yeah the peak
the sword and he's working there and
it's about him as a general for sword
he's not necessarily fighting an action
he's more of a nick fury type now and
he's in charge of getting an avengers
team in space together
kind of like nick fury was right and who
knows what he did in his own timeline he
he could have vastness
yeah yeah he's lived four lifetimes
night by now right it's like
here's a man really combat skill war
knowledge
um ulterior life like alien knowledge so
it's very possible he actually is you
know on the moon or on the sword base
and
working for sword with all of his
knowledge putting together a team
that's young enough and capable enough
of
saving the world from the next thanos
yeah
i mean so cap really is on the moon and
they already told us
i mean pretty much i mean he's the it's
really weird how he's the oldest avenger
as in like
you know when he was introduced it was
the earliest point in time
even before carol danvers right she was
next
um right the first avenger
and he's gonna live to be the oldest
because
well i don't know i don't know how long
carol danvers can live for
um she's still not young or old right
but chris
you know captain america steve rogers
captain america
yeah he's old but that doesn't mean you
know a lot of people like oh captain
died captain died captain died like
well he could live if this takes place
well if the falcon winter soldier and it
does i shouldn't say if
i should state the falcon and winter
soldier takes place six months after
avengers in a game
i don't think steve died in those six
months no i don't i don't think he died
he did he wasn't like
barely able to move he was moving around
just fine and granted it's uh
chris evans it's not really you know
he's not really old but
but he didn't seem like he was on his
deathbed he seemed pretty
good and i think probably peggy died
because he can he's a super soldier he
could you know out live though
yeah um so i think peggy probably died
so
why wouldn't he stay i mean i guess he
has grandkids and stuff like that so
maybe he did go back
right maybe he did go back to his own
timeline but there were a lot of jokes
about him being on the moon so
i don't know i could see him kind of
taking over
a second nick fury role and and being in
charge of
we have so many teams right we're going
to be talking about here in a second
thunderbolts
the young adventures the dark avengers
there's so many different directions
marvel can go and might go for the
future of the mcu
they're going to need leaders yeah and
who better than old captain america
be a leader of one of these groups oh
okay listen here you you teenagers i'm
going to make you the young avengers
right or or possibly a leader of them
all
oh yeah 100 likes and who better to do
it than the first avenger right exactly
nick fury's still a little bit more
hands-on i would definitely expect
samuel jackson to get his hands dirty in
the upcoming
uh secret invasion show plus he's
getting his own show
so i'm expecting a lot more for from sam
jackson nick fury
i think he's still hands on i think oh
yeah i think secret wars for the scrolls
and everything
his attachment to carol danvers and the
scrolls there to talos uh i i think
i think nick fury's about to get his
hands dirty so we'll talk about you
go ahead i'll just say they keep talking
about the two different branches of the
mcu moving forward right the
cosmic the earth side and the cosmic
side and you almost wonder if nick fury
is going to move over and become
the cosmic nick fury you know right
maybe and then chris evans can be the
earth
earth nick fury yeah um
okay so i've seen enough people asking
venom to trailer
so we have been told that it's this
month
uh your times now a few times now
although that is
this is not confirmed um
oh hey pan guy thanks for that super
chat apparently the german subtitles
in one of the episodes for falcon when a
soldier said dead and not gone
um that's always
hard that's always hard because it
depends on how it's translated and who
translated it right like i can speak
several languages
but if you ask me to translate something
it's not going to be perfect
right like it's not going to be perfect
i can actually
understand spanish but i can't really
speak it so if you ask me to translate
it
it's not going to happen say it yeah i
mean
like i can i can read the whole hangul
alphabet but i don't know everywhere
right i could speak conversational
korean but
if you ask me to translate something
it's not gonna it's just not gonna
happen right so
uh but thank you for that super chat
thank you for pointing that out
um yeah someone said
hello up man youtube google translate
nutshell yeah
that's you know if you type in something
at google translate and you like say to
somebody they're
like what because it's not like you know
it's not like word-for-word translation
right because languages don't have some
languages don't have
words right words are particular to a
certain language
it's the meanings that are very very
different but so okay people have been
talking about the venom 2 trailer
apparently it's next week and i say this
uh
i want to say take it with a grain of
salt but daniel rpk i talked to him
frequently um and anytime he's told me
about a trailer
not a leak or a scoop or anything like
that anytime he told me about a
trailer release date it has been right
it's never been wrong it's never been
wrong
um so when when we talk about just the
trailers
just his track record for trailers not
oh i knocked my camera
not not leaks and all this other stuff
he has been right so he said last night
i retweeted it let me take a look
right here
so he said last night
so last thing i retweeted i believe he
said i hear the venom 2 trailer is
coming
soon so likely next week and he
said that the venom 2 trailer should be
this month so we've heard that it's this
month and now we've heard that it's soon
and so if we look at that i mean the
week is over
friday or the month is over friday
in theory which is what i do right
in theory the venom 2 trailer
should be
[Music]
monday to friday i mean that's when we
should have it
is that confirmed no but daniel's track
record for trailers is
insanely good i i can't recall off the
top of my head
when he said a trailer is coming out and
it didn't happen the only time
is uh avengers in game uh the first
trailer for it
he said it was gonna come out on a
wednesday but then uh the former
president bush died and they
claimed that wednesday like national day
morning or something like that in the
united states
so marvel decided not to do it they did
it two days later on friday so
that really wasn't his fault i
definitely don't hold that against him
uh and he did that day say it's not
coming today it's coming friday and it
came friday so
track record is really good um check
ride's really good so for those
that have been asking venom to trailer
hopefully next week um everything points
to it being next week
does that mean it absolutely is coming
no is there a good chance yes
do we see carnage this question they
have to show no i'm sorry
you can't so i know they're going to
show us cletus cassidy because they
already showed us cletus cassidy in the
in the poster right right right but
i think they're going to need to build
hype right right they're going to have
yeah and and it's gonna have to happen
in order to get people excited about
going back to the theaters or however
they plan on releasing it
otherwise so i'm gonna say yes we get a
carnage i think it'll be like a good
two two and a half minute long trailer
we'll see carnage in there a few times
well it's coming out in what october
september
september i believe is where we landed
it's moved so much it's removed
a lot um so where are we at now we're
about to be in may
may june july august oh yeah well it's
really about time for a full-blown
trailer well we don't have a teaser
trailer for it yet
so that's what i'm thinking is it it's
gotta be two minutes
but i think like at the very end they're
just going to show like a red symbiote
going over him
maybe we see his face maybe we see him
open his mouth and we see is there a
rating for this movie
i don't think there is yet not yet
i'm curious what it'll probably be pg-13
though yeah yeah yeah probably you're
right austin
uh one two three and austin always shows
up what up you're right if they don't
show carnage people can be
pissed i'm gonna be pissed um
kenneth oliver is there any truth to the
old cap deleted scene at the end of the
falcon 1 soldier if so wouldn't
that confirm he is still alive whether
they showed it or not uh thank you for
that super chat so that was actually
uh said by uh scooper right
i don't remember who said it might have
been daniel rpk that said it um
and with things like that
it's not you can't confirm it yeah
it's it's a it's a hopeful wish there's
no way to confirm it now what i will say
is in a few days
they're gonna start doing director
interviews and stuff like that
um where things are gonna be revealed
right so that happened after one
division right the director
revealed the uh demon
mr scratchy scene for the finale
right but that's revealed by the
director so
people always ask about deleted scenes
so i would say this upcoming week
after fans have had excuse me have had
time to watch the finale
of the falcon winter soldier in the
upcoming weeks we're going to get a lot
from like the directors the writers and
they're going to come out
and say oh we had this deleted scene and
they're going to say
they're they're they'll reveal most of
the deleted scenes i think um
so you're right if that that would
confirm
that steve rogers is alive if
they have a deleted scene with him in it
but if not
uh we don't know um
it's too hard to confirm it's too hard
to confirm
but if they're doing which is kind of
what we're talking about here
uh another captain america movie
uh i wanna assume he's alive and i i
don't know he's a super soldier
and yeah let's like
let's say he he went back to the other
timeline lived 70 years and came back
like
that's only 70 years to a super soldier
right i mean
he i don't think he's gonna i don't
think he's dead i i'm not buying
that he's dead um i specifically think
even though there are translations right
i specifically
think that if he was dead they would
have said something
because i i guess going back to his
memorial is a thing
but wouldn't sam visit his grave at some
point in time yeah
right asking for help right like what
would you do bud
right what would you do steve i you know
especially when john walker is having
the struggle of
you know i'm losing as captain america
i'm not a super soldier
these flag smashers are and they're and
they're beating me
right and then the dora malaji come up
and he's like they weren't even super
soldiers right
there's this whole struggle of what does
it mean to be captain america what does
it take to be captain america
and sam is dealing with the struggle of
the shield what does it mean you know
they've
like repressed his people and everything
like that isaiah bradley you know what
at some point in time he would he would
go
and just be like what would you do steve
so yeah well there's the other question
about you know
can you stop posting that please i'm
gonna i'll have to time you out if you
push that i see it rated r not pg-13 we
don't have a confirmed thing yet so
yeah go ahead chris i was just gonna say
you have to wonder as well you know he's
obviously older and although he's a
super
soldier not necessarily as capable of
fighting and protecting himself even
and he now has a valuable asset if they
were able to get the super soldier serum
from isaiah's blood
they could get it from captain america
they can get it from chris evans yeah
so he's also potentially in hiding or
you know and it's hard to say
what's happening i think if he were dead
there's no way marvel would have missed
out on
a funeral for him right there's just no
way that's such a huge scene
an emotional scene it'll get fans
involved in the series that they
obviously want to bring traffic to
yeah there's no way they skip that if
he's dead i don't think so
i uh i really don't um yeah
but there's
there's too much you could do with it
right um
and now with that we have this
announcement of a new
captain america movie uh coming to two
new captain america movies one with
steve rogers um
i think he's alive i i don't think he's
dead but but like we were talking about
what what could the chris evans captain
america movie be like it could be what
he did
when he was back in time right it very
well could be
and that would be a good movie i think
i think that would be cool to see
because i think it would be very
different because i don't think he would
be
maybe there was like one instance in the
in that other timeline where he had to
be
captain america right um
yeah i know it's a lot of a lot of
possibilities that they can do with this
so if we're for sure getting a chris
evan captain america movie
it'll be interesting to see where they
lead would be really interesting to see
where it goes with the captain america
chris evans movie now as far as
sam wilson captain america four movie
there's so much there
and uh and i hope bucky comes back for
it
um especially since it's the same
executive producer malcolm spellman
and writer um i say he comes back
and i think a lot of people i don't know
chat let me know right now did you guys
like did you guys like
falcon in the winter soldier the bucky
falcon relationship i thought it was
great
oh i think it's hilarious it was cool to
watch how it
changed throughout you know they're both
kind of resentful towards each other
yeah and the issues that they have they
kind of blame other superheroes
including bucky and sam towards each
other
and then by the end you see that very
heartwarming moment where sam steps up
and becomes captain america and talks to
bucky
bucky gets past his problems and both
the actors are you know ready to go so i
think there's no reason why we shouldn't
see them
continue to team up captain america was
never alone why should sam
right well and it's funny because
captain america had either one of them
right and they only have each so i
definitely think
yeah see everyone i loved it i loved it
yeah yeah
episode six wasn't it i saw a lot of
people actually talking about
how how they didn't like the finale um
there's a few things i would have
changed
but overall i really liked it i really
enjoyed it i liked
john walker's redemption yes
i like that and yeah and i
we won't i don't want to spoil it in
case some people aren't here you know uh
right right i i liked and you don't ha
they're different i've said that i said
this the other night right you don't
really have to choose if you like one
division more falcon and winter soldier
more you can like them both equally
and you don't have to compare the two to
each other because they're very
different but i think i had a better
time watching
the falcon in the winter soldier because
it was more marvel and
um i kind of felt like i was
i had a pretty good handle of what was
going on most of the time
whereas on a vision i was like what is
going on
[Laughter]
which i guess is what they were going
which is what they were going for which
is why you can't judge it
right it did what they wanted to do the
question is is that the right move
uh i i think it was in absolutely the
right move i think it was oh i love you
i think it was great for them to do
something so different and that's why
i'm excited for the eternals
um but the falcon aware soldier
was classic marvel mixed with new marvel
yeah and
in regards to who are the pop heads
next to baby yoda uh zombie hulk
right here and uh tony stark
i have spider-man pointing at then i
have a lot of other i have a lot of
other ones
let's see if i can grab this
i have the spider meme it's from this
zombie hulk
tony stark and the quantum suit
i love these there's a bunch of other
ones you can see them down here
there's some here you know
lots of funkos so so the next captain
america
movie we're getting two new captain
america movies one with chris evans
presumably is what all these you know
sources are telling us
where's my and then another captain
america movie with sam which i think is
the way to go because you know
people are already saying uh falcon
winner soldier two falcon the winner
soldier two falcon the winter soldier
two
which i think it would be
captain america and the white wolf
right right i think it depends if we get
a white wolf series or movie between
because they're still leading on with
the with the winter soldier at the end
of captain of
this season it was captain america and
the winter soldier they're still leading
with it
so i wonder if there's more story they
want to tell there before they
officially change it over
there's a lot yeah um it's really weird
how they're you know
i get the storyline but how it's like
hey you might want to stay clear from
wakanda for a while you know
i'm talking to sam like i i get that uh
take you thanks for the super chat
do you think topher grace's venom will
return and no way home
no but i think that would be so cool now
that you said it i'm not going to be
able to get that out of my head
dang it you're ruined me man right there
um
wow how cool would that be right i mean
i mean how
how cool would that be um so
you know there were talks of which is
like the thumbnail in my video captain
america serpent society
um and with madame hydra
i we don't know if she's madame hydra
right maybe something happens as far as
we know she's valentina
val right now um
you know she she she becomes madame
hydra in the comics
does this have anything to do with the
new movie
the new chris evans captain america
movie or the new sam wilson kept in a
movie
um and now that actually now that i'm
thinking about it now that they
announced all of this
john walker is u.s agent and you know
valentina's involved in this
and zemo and sharon carter well yeah
what else are they going to appear in
there's got to be
a sam wilson captain america movie right
i mean
i mean obviously he didn't become
captain america to pick a nap
right they're not just gonna be like oh
sam's new captain america see you later
no more
falcon soldier or anything like that
anything if anything this is leading
into him becoming the leader of the next
avengers team
right and that's what i talked about in
my video yesterday i i think he is going
to be the leader
right i mean who else right who else
would do it
yeah strange isn't uh
strange might be the most powerful but
he's not trying to lead the event he's
not trying to lead you
technically an avenger right right
the master of the mystic arts yeah he's
got his own priorities and he's the kind
of
character and even human being you know
he's very
focused on what his mission is and his
mission isn't to be an avenger and save
the world it's to do what his
task is protecting your reality
exactly exactly i've saved your reality
as you know it ain't right
what is your job anyways what is what
does tony stark say like what is your uh
or what is your job anyways is you know
uh like working children's birthday
parties or something like that
yeah exactly exactly protecting your
reality douche bag that's what he said
yeah yeah that's protecting your reality
so so fun fun that they're doing this
and
honestly it is slow it is grueling we're
sitting here talking about mephisto and
all these things we want to see in these
seasons
but they're making us work for it yeah
and it's going to build up to something
special though
so we have the famous mephisto
loki stained glass
devil thing i'll show you guys what i'm
talking about if you don't know
oh i gotta pull up another computer and
i'm like how is that not
i i don't understand all right so we got
a google uh
mephisto loki trailer
uh right here
no right here this is in loki check this
out
right how do i open
i don't want to open the link i just
want to open the photo right here
can everybody see this look at this
this is a loki trailer that's owen
wilson right there that's
how is that not mephisto
look at this right here how is that not
mephisto
[Laughter]
so that's on you marvel you made me
think mephisto was coming because of
this oh honestly i think they they um
expected it they were hoping we would do
what we did i think they wanted
to yeah yeah they're gonna pretend like
oh you guys run with it you guys come up
with better ideas than us they know what
they're doing they know what they're
doing
they didn't drop that there for no
reason they didn't drop um
with grim reaper's helmet in one of the
intro scenes on accident
like oh you're right it's not an
accident
[Laughter]
cam k thanks for super chat doc's
manufactured
sun and electra's overcharge leads to
multi-dimensional rift in universe
or do you think it will be all juana's
fault um
i think it's gonna be the blip's fault
um
yeah i think it's going to be the blip's
fault i think they're
i think with all the cosmic energy
because they said that a few times right
in avengers end game i think with all
the cosmic energy
that happened from let's see
three snaps yeah three snaps stannis's
first snap where he got rid of half the
universe
hulk snap where he brought back half the
universe and tony snap where he killed
thanos and his army
that's a lot of cosmic energy to happen
on earth
uh yeah all on earth right uh draw some
attention
yeah and even even if so oh four snaps
thanos used the stones to destroy the
stones
that that's a lot of cosmic energy in
the universe um
there's repercussions to that i feel
like i just felt like i was kevin feige
right there
[Laughter]
you know and there are repercussions to
that it's not you know i love [ __ ]
um alexa
thanks for the super chat i didn't like
sharing as power broker obviously she's
working with someone do you think it
will be a new
character or slash value your thoughts
well that's the next part of what we're
going to talk
about to wrap it up here is the dark
avengers thunderbolts
i think ross is in the background um
i've stated it i stated it many many
different times i've said it many times
that
ross has been you know from incredible
hulk the movie that a lot of people
don't count as mcu cannon it is mcu
cannon
um so from incredible hulk ross
restarted the super soldier program
um and we saw someone smoke his neck oh
shoot oh
snap five step
slogans
[Laughter]
five steps neck that's crazy
um sorry continue no back to alexa super
chat um
i think thunderbolt ross is in the
background um so he started in
the incredible hulk he revamped the
super soldier
program right it's not called the same
he called it uh
weapons plus program and it even says
that on the container for
you know the serum that he's trying to
make um
we see black widow all those red vials
and if we're talking about him becoming
red hulk those red vowels being a super
soldier serum turning him in the red
hulk i
i that's my connection and i i feel like
it's it's right in there no bml beach
boy yeah i loved it i appreciate it
i would have done the same thing um
so so with that with the red vials and
then in
i i really thought we were gonna see him
um and maybe
he maybe he is
my thought was always maybe sharon was
working for him to get
a pardon right because that's kind of
what
thunderbolt ross's thing is like he's
gonna have his thunderbolts team
and all these other people because he's
going to help them
you be be free right he's going to kind
of say
work for me do this team and we'll talk
about you know taking time off your
sentence or setting you free or
something like that
i think that's gonna be i think that's
gonna be the thunderbolts now
i think the dark avengers are going to
come as well i think they are going to
be separate
but you have you have to kind of
you have to kind of realize that the
thunderbolts are
are a group of almost misfits right um
some of them have powers but like zemo
doesn't have powers
but he's a powerful person he's a
powerful character
right and then if you put somebody like
justin hammer who i would love to see
come back he he would be
you know kind of like iron man he he
wouldn't uh he he wouldn't have
powers but like the dark avengers you
know they're
they're like like uh century is part of
it and you know you have a lot of like
powerful characters part of it um like
their own version of iron man wolverine
things like that like
the dark avengers are people with actual
like big
super powers and you know it's very dark
time in the dark rain
storyline for those um
and osborne is iron man
um right not really
but he's leading them and it's like a
privatized avengers team
and it's called the dark avengers
because the the times are dark
um they're not necessarily you know
super evil um that's not really the
thing it's just a really dark storyline
so
i think we're kind of getting into that
um it got kind of dark
in falcon winter soldier a little bit um
not too dark but i think it can go that
way
um i do think we saw the darkest scene
in the mcu when john walker
killed uh nico
um that was pretty intense
now they didn't show like his face
getting bashed in or anything like that
but
chris we were talking we were like that
has to be a dark
like probably the darkest moment right i
mean oh yeah and
and i go off of what i said in a video
not too long ago about this is test
footage you know the mcu is trying to
open up expand they're going in
different directions
they're not gonna leave what they know
but they're also gonna try other things
you got moon knight
blade oh yeah so many more coming
out now and they're kind of trying to
see how people reacted and i think a lot
of people liked it
in the sense that they could feel the
reality of john walker and
as much as we loved to hate john walker
what a great job he did
portraying those emotions on screen
bashing somebody's face in
and then his redemption arc leading to
him becoming u.s agent so marvel knows
what they're doing we got to trust them
and just wait to see how this all is
going to become something huge for him
yeah we're all so enjoying yeah i agree
uh for someone just asked is mo
modoc has no connection to the mcu right
yet no absolutely it's
no connection it's a stop-motion series
that i'm actually excited to
to watch but yeah no no connection
whatsoever but
i think falcon winter soldier did a good
job of setting up more of a
darker path that they can take
not like super dark and like super
intense because that's just not what
marvel's going to do
but yeah right like uh
are you not from the dc universe
um but they are gonna do something with
zemo again like that character people
people loved zemo and i know there's
some people out there that didn't but i
think the vast majority of
people really love zemo and i don't
think this is a character
that that's just going to go away
and we know that sharon carter is up to
no good she has something going on
we know that u.s agent now john walker
is working with valentina and i think
valentina is working with sharon in some
way and i think thunderbolt ross is
connected
and i do think that the thunderbolts are
coming now
grace randolph um depending or not if
you know she her track record's like
she gets some she doesn't get some she
gets some she doesn't get some so you
never really know
but she said that her sources did tell
her yes thunderbolts aren't coming
yes the dark avengers are coming they
are separate separate
and i believe that because of everything
i've heard before that right
um i've been doing videos on the
thunderbolts coming for
even before i really thought falcon and
winter soldier was going to set him up
because
that's what we've been hearing so i
think that's the part
i think that's one of the upcoming parts
of
the mcu it's the thunderbolts and the
dark avengers and hopefully
fingers freaking crossed spider-man no
way home introduces
norman osborne at least one of them
right
the old one william defoe or or a new
one coming in to take over that avengers
tower
and then we have norman osborne then we
could get the dark avengers because
you know someone stupid rich like norman
osborne and stupid smart
uh you know taking iron man's technology
making his own iron man suit that's
entirely plausible yeah 100
entirely plausible so but that's what's
happening today guys
we got some words of uh two new
captain america movies coming one based
off of sam wilson's
and another one based off of chris evans
is captain america
so that'll be super cool yeah
that'll be uh super cool to see that
story
um venom 2 trailer is reportedly coming
out next week
um i believe next friday is the end of
the month so it's supposed to come out
before then or on friday so we'll be
we'll be looking out for that
and then we have the thunderbolts and
the dark avengers that are going to be
coming down the line
mixed with everything else that we have
coming
like the future the mcu is like super
super exciting and they're they're
getting different
which is why i like the fact that the
dark vendors are coming but but i think
it's really cool that
they had one division which was so
different and then they had falcon and
winter soldier which was so familiar
because it's like we're not going to
abandon what we do
but we are going to give you a different
idea of what we can do and i think
that's really really
really cool and i think we're going to
get a lot of exciting
movies and shows because of that i i
think
i think it's going to be cool put on
your seatbelt boys we're going into race
mode yeah for real uh mr
donkey biscuits uh i think there's a
chance tony stark could be in black
widow i think he could go see her and
try to get her to come back
um but i would not count on it
that way uh you're not super
disappointed if it doesn't happen
so yeah so
two captain america movies venom two
trailer should be coming out next week
should according to the reports
again i'm not the one getting the
knowledge i'm just repeating what i
heard um
and thunderbolts dark avengers
spider-man home
rated r section of the mcu blade you
know all that stuff coming
it's exciting so so much so hey we're
going to be doing these shows these live
shows a little bit more now we don't
have a title for it we were going to
call it
talk nerdy to me we'll do a poll
comment below what you think our show
should be called where me and chris
uh talk about everything that's
happening and uh if you're not
subscribed to cosmic culture that's
chris and my
other channel be sure to do that we're
giving away captain america shield
uh friday uh this upcoming friday we're
gonna oh
he chris just dropped the link in the
comments so we're giving away this
shield right here it's unopened
in the box giving it away on friday uh
go ahead and subscribe to cosmic culture
uh we're gonna pick a winner from
somebody who's subscribed to both of us
and we'll be announcing that on friday
we're going to pick the winner on friday
so
be sure to click those links in the
descriptions there um and
comment down below what you think our
show should be called
uh yeah yeah make it cool though yeah
what do people do on twitter um you know
what is this wrong answers only
name our show wrong
[Laughter]
don't do that no we need like a good we
need a cool name i need to be cool i've
been a nerd my whole life
um hardcore graphic novel discussion
minute
yeah comment comments
that's i will mess that up so many times
chris is dyslexic that's what i was
going to say
hey aj xylo thanks for that super chat
nerd and nerdier i
actually kind of like that dibs on nerd
[Laughter]
fine the nerdier and nerd then
i'm fur i i like that okay
that's on the board that's on the board
let me write that down nerd and nerdier
nerd and nerdier uh not bad
nerd and nerdy we were thinking
talk nerdy to me but i think that might
be a handful to put in the titles of our
videos
uh that was a past project
it was a past project um the wonder dome
wonder dome yeah it was wonder dome
wonder doom
actually kind of like wonder doom better
than wonder
dang it this is why we should have gone
to the people cosmic nerds
that's not bad cosmic nerds nerds
because we both are cosmic
cosmic nerds because cosmic culture
cosmic wonder
so cosmic culture started off as like
something that i was trying to do to
talk about other movies and then
uh cosmic wonder just kind of you know
took off
bigger than i expected and there's so
much definitely a lot more content than
i expected wow
i mean i was not expecting marvel to be
doing three shows a year and on top of
three movies a year
and it's crazy so chris came in clutch
and started helping me with that and
then it kind of just became his little
baby
and then i'm on there when we do live
reactions and stuff like that
cosmic avengers nice bricks with bricky
hey i appreciate that thank you so much
uh juan casas what did you
[Music]
is that are you the one who told us
cosmic cosmic nerds
are you the one who calls that we'll
have to remember that juan
casas how do you
how would you pronounce that spanish
last name casas
chris sorry i wasn't paying chris lived
in mexico for
two years yeah yes
i'm actually mexican and uh all my
family speaks spanish and i understand
spanish
i just can't i lived in mexico for two
years yeah i just can't really speak
spanish that well uh cosmic chat
cosmic chat cosmic talks cosmic talk the
wonder place
sounds like an off-brand superhero well
hey we'll do a poll
uh yeah yeah yeah and we can throw a few
names on there
and and uh did i write yeah cause we'll
throw a few names out there
and then we'll we'll put like a fifth
option where you vote and you tell us
what you think it is and then
uh cosmic live cosmic world
cosmic chats mikasa sukasa
yes casas okay uh cosmic world
uh where's the time i'm at
um it's 405 pm
where are you at you're in england uh
yeah it's still light out i have like i
just have my
i like my studio lights and all the
stuff like that set up uh but
uh we live in in america uh hey
son wolkong thank you appreciate that so
uh cosmic nerds seems like a lot of
people write cosmic around cosmic
theories you know cosmic theory i
actually made a
uh a intro for cosmic theory
uh mccoy made me one uh oh yeah i
remember that
so maybe cosmic theory let's write that
down because i used to do theory
thursday
and i changed the times of my life those
were dark times
cosmic theory hey way metal
super what's from whey middle cosmic
universe so
that was actually what cosmic culture
used to be we decided we liked culture
more i was going to say fun fact cosmic
culture
used to be called cosmic universe that's
what i named it at first and then i
changed it so
i still don't hate talk nerdy to me no
it's just a handful to put in a title
but anyways we'll do a poll
um yeah we'll do a poll and see what
everybody thinks about it so
hey this was fun guys i'm going to be
doing some more live streams like that
with chris be chris that way yeah be
sure to follow chris
on cosmic culture we do some awesome
videos over there and we're giving away
this shield right here on friday
i'll get you a shield boys yep so look
out for my next video coming up on
monday i take sundays off just to kind
of
have a date to myself
chit chat cosmic chick chat cosmic show
cosmic talk the wonder cosmo cosmic
comedian
we're gonna have uh a lot of different
things coming in so we'll do that paul
so all right guys hey everyone have a
great great weekend everybody stay safe
love you all thank you so much for
being an awesome community and we'll see
you next time woof woof
bye guys oh wait no aj's island
captain cosmic and the wonder soldier
yeah
[Laughter]
captain cosmic there's no way you're
capturing us
captain cosmic and the cosmic old church
that's fantastic thank you so much
for that we're gonna work with that all
right guys no more super chats because
we're heading now